I'd like to show you some interesting
connections between
why you may develop gallstones
or have gallbladder problems and its
relationship to the thyroid okay or if
you have a hypothyroid problem how that
could relate to your gallbladder in bile
salts I really wish it was easier to
find these connections when you do your
research on these topics but it's been
difficult but I did it and I'm going to
summarize it right here there's some
real interesting relationships between
the gallbladder and your thyroid and
unfortunately this is the type of thing
that your doctor should be telling you
so let's first start out talking about
what is bile bile is composed of many
things you first of all have bile salts
in the bile and that's made out of
potassium sodium
calcium bicarbonates are like a compound
that is alkaline and it's also made out
of chlorides
so 67 percent of bile is bile salts but
then you also have something else in
bile salts and that's called lecithin so
22 percent of bile is made out of
lecithin and lecithin is a choline
compound that helps you break down fat
and cholesterol so bile is made out of
bile salts
lecithin which has choline in it also
bile is made up of cholesterol and
that's really how bile salts are created
from cholesterol and if there's too much
cholesterol and not enough bile salts
that's when you get gallstones so we
have the cholesterol we also have
bilirubin which is like the end product
of red blood cells and you have a little
bit of protein in there and transported
through the body okay so that term is
called conjugated okay so that allows it
to travel through the body in a very
similar way to cholesterol being
attached to a protein that's why they
called an ellipoprotein to be
transported through the blood and then
as these bile salts travel through the
intestine bacteria
take the amino acids away and then they
unconjugate it and then now it's allowed
to be recycled and so one of the really
important purposes of the liver is to
make bile and bile is the primary mode
of cholesterol elimination and also a
lot of the drugs and chemicals and
toxins are eliminated with the help of
this bile and of course bile has another
purpose of helping you break down fats
and helping in the absorption of vitamin
A d e and K omega-3 fatty acids very
very very important and one point about
this cholesterol the majority of
cholesterol in the body is actually made
by your own body
you have dietary cholesterol which is
about 25 but 75 percent of the
cholesterol is made by your own body and
this cholesterol is really necessary to
help you make bile to help you make
hormones especially like estrogen
progesterone and even the stress hormone
called cortisol also you make Vitamin D
from cholesterol so cholesterol is
really really important now what's
interesting about the thyroid is when
the thyroid is low you have this
hypothyroid condition and even if it's
subclinical so it's not like a major
problem it's a smaller problem that is
going into the direction of a full-blown
hypothyroid situation the person has a
susceptibility a developing stones and
when someone is treated with thyroid
hormones okay T4 for example
a lot of times these Stones go away so
the more thyroid hormones you have the
less you're at risk for developing
Stones so that's one interesting
relationship also when the thyroid is
sluggish as in hypothyroidism the
production of bile salts goes down and
so if you're not making the bile salts
guess what you're going to get
costumes also without enough thyroid
hormones the metabolism of cholesterol
is diminished here you are having all
this cholesterol in the body but it's
not really broken down it's not
metabolized you can't really use it the
receptors for LDL don't even actually
work so you get the situation where
you're getting a buildup of more
cholesterol without the bile to break it
down and so again we have another risk
of getting gallstones because we're
getting more cholesterol the body can't
use it without the bile salts so you
have this super saturated cholesterol
Stone that's developing also your bile
ducts won't be able to relax if the
thyroid hormones are sluggish
so in a hypothyroid case you can develop
stones in the ducts because they're kind
of more constricted or you can develop
stones in the gallbladder itself and
then there's another connection if the
thyroid is sluggish you're going to be
on the cold side and at the temperature
in your body is too cold guess what the
enzymes don't work anymore so now the
enzymes in the pancreas are not going to
help you break down this fat the
activation of the enzymes in the liver
are not going to be that great as well
as the formation of bile all right so we
have that connection right we have this
hypothyroid problem that can create
Stones right now on the flip side
bile salts help in the conversion of T4
to T3 to actually activate the thyroid
hormones you see T4 is the inactive
version of the thyroid hormone T3 is the
active version to help this conversion
bile is needed so you may have a lot of
thyroid hormone like T4 but you can also
experience the symptoms of a hypothyroid
because they're not being activated so
we have two problems one is are you
producing enough thyroid hormone or is
the problem the conversion okay so you
have to differentiate which is which it
takes a really healthy thyroid to make
good bile but it also takes bile to
actually create a healthy thyroid the
one big common problem probably the most
common problem with a hypothyroid
situation is that the person has an
autoimmune type hypothyroid situation
it's called Hashimoto's in that case
there's a completely different mechanism
it's not really a thyroid problem per se
it's an immune problem that's attacking
the thyroid so you have antibodies and I
actually have a really good protocol and
I will put that link down below if you
have Hashimoto's
90 of everyone with hypothyroidism has
um Hashimoto's okay and for that you
definitely need to avoid gluten and
Grains for sure another common cause of
thyroid problems is a high level of
cortisol it's adrenal stress and that
can shut down the thyroid so the thyroid
is secondary the adrenal is primary and
a couple reasons for that it could be
stress or let's say you're menopausal
right and you're going through this
transition where your adrenals are
backing up the ovaries and let's say
you're on a low fat low cholesterol diet
well your adrenal hormones like cortisol
and other hormones like estrogen and
progesterone are made out of cholesterol
so if you are on a low fat diet or a
plant-based diet you're not going to get
enough cholesterol and that could be the
very reason why the adrenals tank down
and the thyroid goes down because you
don't have the raw material to make
these hormones just by supplying more
fat going on a healthy version of the
ketogenic diet can supply the raw
material to start making more adrenal
hormones that can then reduce the
cortisol situation and give relief to
your thyroid and remember it takes
cholesterol to make bile so being on a
low-fat diet or a low cholesterol diet
can cause you not to even make enough
bile to not activate the thyroid
hormones so we need that cholesterol
also what activates the production of
bile is fat in the diet animal fats so
if you're not having enough animal fats
don't make enough bile that right there
can increase your risk of gallstones as
well as your risk of gaining a
hypothyroid situation because one we
don't feed the adrenal hormones okay so
then we get higher cortisol and we don't
make enough bio to make the conversion
from T4 to T3 so as you can see there's
a lot of different things going on
there's some complexities but I wanted
you to understand some of these
important connections so you can have a
light bulb go off and make some changes
because I think it's really important to
just look at all these factors and
figure out what the real problem is
instead of just being on your medication
for the rest of your life and not really
ever coming off of it there's a couple
other reasons for hypothyroidism one is
you don't have enough selenium in the
diet you don't have enough iodine in the
diet and your estrogen might be too high
so to help you sort out more of really
what's causing your thyroid problem in
the first place you might want to check
this video out right here